i remember actually joe wright coming up
to me one of the first scenes we shot
was with with dame judy dench and i had
dreams actual dreams about working with
with judy dench when i was a teenager
and i was suddenly in the scene with her
and and we did a couple of takes and
it's the scene where she marches into
the house in the middle of the night and
wakes us all up
and um we did about four takes and joe
came over to me and very sweetly
whispered in my ear and he said um
carrie you actually need to do something
with your face because i was just sort
of staring at her you know the whole
thing was just so
like gormlessly like
oh dude you don't but your parents were
reluctant for you to go into acting what
was the reason for that and how did you
persuade them or did you just not listen
oh i didn't persuade them um yeah they
were you know for all the reasons that
you would imagine
you know and the reasons that i now can
rationally see a very good reason
um but at the time yeah they were very
worried about it being a kind of
unreliable job and um and a very
disappointing one and a difficult one um
so yes they weren't um sort of that into
the idea and i tried to find my way and
i applied to lots of drama schools i was
rejected by all of them and
well i don't know you know i was like 17
years old and going into these
auditions and doing sarah kane pieces
about suicide and trying to be very deep
and had you know absolutely nothing to
to draw from and i think you know they
saw straight through me and quite
rightly didn't let me in um and and then
i went on to sort of get my first job
just after i left school so that was
sort of my way in
well opportunity not for you when julian
fellowes the downton abbey creator came
to give a talk at your school and you
followed up tell us the story about how
he was initially uh not so helpful but
then ultimately became helpful to your
career
yeah he told i said i want to be an
actress and he said well
marry a banker
or a lawyer um
and um and that was sort of it and then
uh after i was rejected by all the drama
schools i contacted him through my
headmistress and i said you're the only
actor i've ever met and um
you know i don't have any kind of root
into this and i think if i go to draw to
university then i'll drop out and that's
a waste of time so you know what advice
can you offer and he took me out for
dinner with his wife and a lot of other
people who'd obviously also written
these sort of letters and um
and they were amazing they they sort of
recommended a brilliant workshop theater
kind of television film workshop in
london at riverside studios that i went
to every week for about a year
and um they also told me that there was
an open casting happening and that gina
j um who cast pride and prejudice her
assistant was meeting lots of young
girls who never acted before to um to
play one of the sisters and pride and
prejudice so i went and met um robin who
was genius assistant and did an audition
tape my first audition tape which um he
very much coached me through because i
was doing a very big theatrical
performance and he kept on trying to
sort of he kept kind of making less yeah
do less do less um and and that turned
into my first job
and what a first job to have 2005's
pride and prejudice directed by joe
wright you must have thought oh this is
easy
you know here i am you know with with
keira knightley judy dench all the rest
i imagine it was something of a
educational experience for you as well
to be surrounded by all this great
talent you know were you like a sponge
back then what did you learn yeah i mean
i you know i was i had very little to do
and i had a and that was the case for a
lot of the jobs i did in the first
couple of years i was kind of supporting
supporting and um and it was great you
know the the most extraordinary people
in that film brenda blethen and donald
sutherland and um and kira and rosamund
pike and and in a way they also became
kieran ross and simon woods and all
those guys kind of became my year group
because i didn't go to drama school so
we're all you know kind of the same age
and um but yeah i just got to watch you
know judy dench and and and all these
extraordinary actors actors and
actresses and and no one was focusing on
me and uh and so i could make lots of
mistakes and you know and just learn a
lot
um you've mentioned not going to drama
school there now uh drama school teaches
you a lot about the the process and
building a character so um i i guess
with the classes you had you had to sort
of find your own way uh tell us how you
set about building a character
i didn't really have a way of working
until i mean on pride and prejudice i
literally copied everything jenna malone
did i mean to like everything and the
way that she laughed i would laugh and
you know the way that she delivered the
line i would i just thought you know i
had no idea i remember actually joe
wright coming up to me one of the first
scenes we shot was with with dame judy
dench and i had dreams actual dreams
about working with with judy dench when
i was a teenager and i was suddenly in
this scene with her and and we did a
couple of takes and it's the scene where
she marches into the house in the middle
of the night and wakes us all up
and um we did about four takes and joe
came over to me and very sweetly
whispered in my ear and he said um
carrie you actually need to do something
with your face because i was just sort
of staring at her you know the whole
thing was just so
like gormlessly like oh dude you don't
um
so yeah it was a very but so so i didn't
really have a way but i remember had to
cry in that film and
i didn't know how to so i just thought
about my mum dying you know i imagine
terrible things happening to my family
to make myself crying that's sort of how
i worked for the first couple of years i
was just sort of making it up as i went
along and didn't really know well one of
those jobs you did in the first couple
of years was a tv movie my boy jack and
uh in that you have to
um your brother is about to go off to
war and you're you're terrified about it
now around this time your own brother um
was a captain in the in the british army
so
did was that an experience where you
channeled your own feelings and put them
into the role or do you do not like to
go that close yeah i think it probably
was um yeah i think it was my brother
had gone off to iraq and um
and it was probably the closest i've
felt in
in a lot of ways to some of the
characters that i played i mean i very
rarely have anything you know to draw
from thankfully because some of the
characters i played at awful and um
so
yeah that was probably the closest to it
um
but it's funny it's a really difficult i
it sort of feels like such a long time
ago it's quite hard to imagine what it
was like back then but yeah i think um
i think i did sort of have a lot of
angst as well that my brother was there
at the time and so it was a sort of odd
experience
your breakthrough role on the
international stage came in an education
there were so many actresses up for that
part how did you set about winning the
role
an education actually happened over a
couple of years it was originally it had
a terrible title originally it's called
the time of her life
um
which which sounded so dodgy um when you
watch the film um but um
anyway yeah so it kind of it was over
and it had a different director
originally and then that changed and
then at one point um some time had
passed and and i was being seen for
helen which is the role that rosman pike
plays instead and um and then it finally
came back round and it was with loan
surfing
um
and so and then it all came together
quite quickly all in a couple of weeks
and suddenly it was happening and maybe
someone else dropped out i don't looking
back now maybe that's what happened but
um but so and then we started shooting
it so it was all kind of a whirlwind
getting into that film and i did
a number of auditions for it so i think
that was just a whittling down process
and talking of whirlwind what was it
like going through awards season i mean
your first sort of major movie as a lead
there you are you're winning the bafta
you're nominated for everything else how
do you look back on that experience now
what are your memories of it oh it was
amazing you know um
i had no expectations for an education
at all and um and and didn't really know
what sundance was and um
you know found the whole thing quite
overwhelming and um and i really
expected it to come out in the cursing
in london and you know for no one to see
it so it was
amazing and it meant that i suddenly was
sort of very quickly elevated to
a point where i was getting offered
things i'd never been offered anything
before i'd always auditioned a lot um
and it opened the door for me to be able
to never let me go which i did kind of
straight after that um so it was it was
amazing i think i was a bit freaked out
and i probably took it way too seriously
and you know i was really nervous all
the time and um
and sort of yeah the whole thing was you
know a big kind of
change very quickly
and talking of big change you're then
sort of whisked off to the united states
and you do a mega movie like wall street
uh money never sleeps so uh tell us tell
us what that experience was like to
suddenly find yourself in the american
movie big leagues
yeah odd you know and and
brilliant at the same time i mean it was
again another example you know it was
sort of i never would have had that in a
million years before in education and
suddenly that was a possibility for me
and i was working with oliver stone and
you know that was kind of extraordinary
i think i kind of felt quite out of my
depth at that point and so
looking back i'm probably
i mean i'm quite critical but i i sort
of didn't really find my feet in that
project quite so much i don't think
but it was a great opportunity and and
it kind of you know these all these
things sort of add up and give you the
the opportunities that you you're
looking for so i and i really enjoyed
the experience making it but it was
challenging and i was very very kind of
you know doing an american accent and i
hadn't quite figured it out yet and it
was lots of kind of it was a bit of a
battle for me though
and you were balancing uh stage work in
broadway and the west end as well at
this period how important was it for you
to uh go to the stage at this period
rather than just do movie after movie
i mean the stage was where the roles
were really in sometimes i mean when i i
did the seagull when i was 21 in london
at the royal court and then did it on
broadway um and
it was just my favorite experience of my
career and and i i mean my very short
career up until then but uh i loved it
so much and i i was i couldn't imagine
finding another role like that that i
loved as much and so when i did an
education i had a conversation with my
agent tal and she said you know you're
in this extraordinary position now
briefly and it might be brief
where people are going to offer you
things um and it's an amazing privilege
but as long as you're in it you mustn't
take a role unless you can't bear the
idea of anybody else doing it um and so
that became my sort of way of working
that when i was offered things if i kind
of the next day i'm not really thinking
about it or i think well it would be
fine if so and so took that part
i've let it go
[Music]
[Music]